stockfish and Komodo played in the
computer Chess Championships the other
day and the end game that ensued was all
the rage all the discussion on social
media with everybody in their cousin
having their minds blown by stock fish's
ability to generate something out of
nothing in this very very long same
color Bishop ending but before we dive
into all the brilliance that was and get
to the 99th move that had the world
talking I want to say that this
particular position here even for the
most studious of chess experts who've
been following the analysis might bring
a little bit more insight at the end of
the video the question I posed was
whether Komodo at any point had a
different way to try to defend the
position was there something else to do
and the only thing I could really find
starts right here right now on move 84
in the position with King f5 sacrificing
the h5 pawn may have actually caused a
little bit more trouble for stockfish to
win that that first meets the eye so
we're gonna come back to this and
describe exactly why giving up a pawn
versus taking one as Komodo eventually
did was may be the key defensive
strategy but without any further ado or
foreshadowing let's dive in to what I
deemed is the first kind of critical
moment when we should start analyzing
and learning from stock Fischer's
brilliant technique so I'll move 43
rather than making some sort of trade or
heading into a draw and ending we see
the move f5 from stock fish and he
clearly declares his intention that he
wants to play this endgame on no
surprise after Bishop EA King III and
King e5 we see the move Bishop c8 and
now Bishop b5 what's gonna happen here
over the next few minutes in the video
is gonna be a little bit of computer
chess shuffle puck and what I mean by
that and often wrote in my analysis you
can find it the blog grandmaster damn
boy cop did a great job for Peter
Dockers news report on this game that's
how great it was a full news report on
it is that sometimes you wonder when
computers are shuffling in life fashion
if it's just the contempt that has them
going contempt for those who don't speak
computer chess is something that
programmers have put into our
artificially intelligent overlords to
say don't take a draw we want to be
entertained play it out to the bitter
bitter end so unless you see a variation
that's completely a forced loss for you
then you should always avoid repetition
so sometimes as we see the next few
moves f6 sacrifice
obviously that makes sense to try to
force that came back in gained ground
but after Bishop to e2 and then takes we
get a whole lot of shuffling here
Bishop c6 Bishop around and the bishops
and Kings and bishops and Kings are
going to shuffle for a very very long
time the reason I didn't spend a ton of
time highlighting for example that f6
was some brilliant sacrifice to force
the King back just to get more activity
with the King is as you just saw over
the next few moves really just a lot of
shuffling occurred in fact white
willingly sacrifices back this e5 square
if Komodo is man enough so to speak or
lizard enough to take it but Komodo
doesn't need to take it because the main
thing he knows that he needs to do to
blockade or draw the sending is to make
sure that neither of his two biggest
weaknesses H 5 or a 6 fall at any point
now it sounds a little bit easier said
than done right maybe we're
foreshadowing we should have seen that
stockfish had winning chances but
there's really only one way you could
ever create such a scenario and the
reason I'm pausing to stop right now is
because we're gonna really appreciate
how hard it was to get that in the long
run if you could ever get your Bishop to
ask where there's only one that attacks
both a6 and h5 and somehow have the
ability that also in that scenario black
was in zoogs Wang meaning the King had
to somehow give up the g5 square or the
bishop on a square like c8 would have to
leave the pawn on a6 without a scenario
like that you're never gonna have
winning chances here right and as we go
through we're gonna see that white tries
a number of different things a whole lot
of tickle a whole lot of shuffle puck
but black is always there in time to
guard the pawn and say what you got next
big boy
the bishop checks and the King stays
here the King gets it advancing square
and at first you think oh we're making
progress here but no don't get too
excited the King comes to g6 and we
learn a new problem even if you get
Bishop b7 you haven't necessarily
reached the ideal diagonal because black
takes that all critical e to square
holding both a6 and h5 so white tries to
stop you from being an option and black
then goes back to c8 we get a bit of
rinse and repeat by the way this
position has now occurred twice so you
better come up with something new and
stock fish tries to do that Bishop a4
the King's again are shuffling around
and after Bishop h3 the Bishop comes
back forcing the King back Bishop a4 he
doesn't want to
repeated three times only then does he
come back to f4 and eventually we see
the bishop try its new and ideal
diagonal of hitting h5 followed by
coming to e2 so now we're gonna pause
here and try to gather some instruction
I foreshadowed that this was the ideal
position a few moments ago right your
Bishop is on the ideal square hitting a6
and h5 your King is threatening entry at
least sort of bluffing it the idea that
it might be able to come forward closer
look reveals that hey every single one
of those squares is guarded by a black
piece but at least here we can see okay
we've got a good position for the white
pieces now how to make black give up
something and this is this is really
instructive because you should pause
just to just to consider that even if
you don't see a win when you play in
games like this the way to piece
together the proper plan is something
that I've learned from all of my coaches
and trainers and can pass on is to is to
build a bridge or to sort of piece
together a plan you don't solve these
end games by calculating I go there he
goes there for a million moves it's not
possible you solve them by visualizing
well if I could get all my pieces on
this squared this square on this square
and it was my opponent's turn
I've made progress right cuz they're in
six long or if I could get my king here
or my Bishop here or my rook here and
some random ending clearly that's
progress even if you don't know if it's
a win or not if you have sort of pieced
together the types of positions that's
clearly signify improvement once you get
those something new might pop into your
head right and that sounds crazy we're
talking about something new pumping into
stock Fischer Komodos head they don't
really have one but it is kind of what
happens here and it's almost where the
contempt factor actually made him
approach it like a human being
stock fish didn't necessarily have a
winning plan when it was making all of
these last few moves we saw a whole lot
of rinse and repeat without any real
progress right but at least once this
position occurs you could now clearly
see if you were the human being playing
white then okay even the ideal position
here is not good enough there's no way
to make progress I'm gonna give checks
I'm gonna try to place shuffle puck here
this almost looks like a triple step
method for the bishop which is where you
move to three squares to try to get the
same position you have here but instead
of it being white to move you try to get
this same position to be black to move
we're gonna see that's what he does here
he gets that same position with black to
move well here's the problem the bishop
just goes to be
seven right the point is you got this
same position with black to move and it
would work if the bishop had to leave
this diagonal okay or if for example
that King had to leave h6 and go here
you would lose the pawn right and if the
King had to go to here now you can go
back to d3 and threaten Bishop a5
there's no way to get there and stop the
trade because that would be check
so it seems suddenly that okay we've got
the ideal position the triple step
method work I have the position I
visualize and it's black to move but
there is no zoogs along black and waste
and as you give check and I go and I
move my King you can't both be
threatening to enter and have pressure
on the h5 pawn at the same time Bishop
goes back and the King goes back the
King goes to e4 and the bishop goes back
so again as we rinse and repeat this
this process I don't know why I keep
talking about that probably because I
need to you know I don't know switch
shampoos or something
we finally get a point where we've seen
no progress to be made
coming back to any of these squares is
not gonna work
we should note that at no point is black
ever threatening to take the d5 pawn if
a six is hanging that's a big if so part
of the reason that the whole method I
was just showing you work is that black
is actually frozen here at least to some
degree that d5 is not captured without a
six falling just to show lines like that
if we if we want to see it and prove it
Bishop takes d5 Bishop takes a six no
matter what black does the bishop will
either enter c8 or b7 next and the pawn
will start marching one key point is
that if the bishop moves and although
there you could just go to b7 I guess if
the bishop moves somewhere to prevent b7
ok and it comes and you come here and
they push you have to make sure you have
Bishop b7 first as the key idea in your
mind pushing the pawn all the way to a7
you'll never have a chance to help it
again which is just an instructive way
to Queen corner pollens when you have
same kind of bishops I wanted to show
you got a little off track there but
sorry the chess teacher in me sometimes
takes a hold and I wanted to make sure
you understand that if you got this pawn
the threat is Bishop b7 and then you
advance not anything else so that that's
a good example of why D 5 is not being
taken because of a6 and and white will
always win that race but with with the
shuffle that
we got this position where it seems like
nothing nothing new is being done are we
ready finally two to agree that it's
enough contempt with the contempt and
just agree to a draw no stock version of
something else King to d2 now this was
the first move I really gave as an ex
clan because at the very least it showed
how a human would think you got this
sort of ideal position with the king a
bishop no progress to be made
in order to keep the game alive we might
as well make an exchange reset all of
those three move repetition ideas so
there's no draw also you reset the 50
move rule not that that was really a
threat but you do do that and eventually
you've changed the structure enough that
you can go back and try to find
something new players who try to win
these drawn endings have to be stubborn
they have to keep fighting win even if
there's a little part of them inside
that says oh this is probably just a
drop you don't give in to that voice you
push and you dictate your opponent until
they get under time pressure and
eventually beat themselves that's just
random george & grandmaster advice right
okay so we reach the position that I'm
going to show after the video King to be
free I think that in hindsight what
we've now learned is despite all of my
sort of trying to take the slightly
pessimistic tone I'm an entertainer
trying to twist ending you to say no
this really was just a draw I actually
think that at this point white does have
a threat of a winning plan and having
analyzed it really deeply I don't think
comodo could have done anything
different than perhaps right here right
now with the immediate abandonment of
the H pawn and trying for a new blockade
so I will circle back and show the idea
that that isn't so obvious here in a
little bit but first let's get back to
our position that we saw and and stop
teasing us Dan let's get the exact same
position you saw why is it any different
now right
a lot of shuffle puck a lot of moves we
get back to the exact same position we
had right here we had already seen this
position a few times King goes you move
the King moves we've seen we've now seen
this position whether the bishop was on
c8 or the King was on h6 enough times
right if the bishop goes back to e2
we're gonna see the move King to g6 and
with check the King can come back if the
bishop continues to wait this Bishop can
continue to wait on this diagonal so
without anything new to show you have a
really made any progress yet a stock
fish but this is the move that blew
everybody's mind and in hindsight we're
gonna say that not only was it brilliant
I don't think it was just based on some
sort of random contempt later by Comodo
losing a drawn position I think that
black is actually lost after the double
exclam Bishop f5 giving up the d5 pawn
but not in a position where you can win
the a6 pawn back right away that's the
key every other position before you can
go through the whole video whenever the
d5 pawn was hanging a six would have
always come with it and this position
was the first time that stock fish
realizes however you want to talk about
how an artificially intelligent being
comes to think that he doesn't need the
d5 pawn what's amazing is that in one of
the things this shows is that two
weaknesses are often more more important
than one right we know that right thanks
for the memo Captain Obvious but it does
show that the idea is that just because
you give up your weakness doesn't mean
that those two weaknesses have gone away
so what I'm saying is you still have the
chance to win both weaknesses and what
you start to realize is that this d5
pawn if it's actually impinge on your
ability to gang up or to put your
opponent in a zoogs wrong where those
the weaknesses are not defensible then
why why do you need it right in end
games one principle should always hold
true it's not how many pawns you have
but who Queens first and as you look at
those pawns you realize that they have
to think one thing in common they're
both corner pawns they're both rook
pawns those are the hardest pawns to
stop in chess and games right because
they're completely separate from each
other central pawns are often the
easiest pawns to stop because you can
reach them from both sides of the board
and if you have a centralized King which
white does you're almost never in real
danger of that pawn becoming a queen so
Bishop f5 is translated as well you
don't need it and you're probably not
risking losing anyway so you might as
well go for it Bishop takes d5 is played
because what else if the King retreats
in any kind of way the white King can
enter into g5 moving the bishop to a e8
would immediately allow Bishop to c8
so this is quite literally the only move
Bishop takes d5 this is the real shy I
almost found this move just as funny as
Mitch replied the bishop goes right back
to d3 so
you played the move Bishop at five to
give up the d5 pawn and then you go
right back to d3 and what what have you
done now the bishop comes to c4 and
after the king goes to g6 we get Bishop
e2 this is the exact same position we
had just a few moments ago except the d5
pawn is gone how in the world is it
possible that this has improved your
winning chances well
after Bishop to c8 we see the move
Bishop of three and it suddenly starts
to come to light without the d5 pawn you
actually have access that you didn't
before note that there really isn't any
any better ways for black to try to hold
I've analysed a few of them here for you
so let's see pushing the D pawn in an
attempt to keep the bishop here simply
allows the move king to e5 and as we're
gonna see in a lot of variations here
that do get kind of complicated once the
King enters your king can be pushed back
and this a six pawn is a much bigger
problem than almost anything else that
that black can't drum up so entering
into e5 is a real threat and black
doesn't want to allow it moving the King
away from the H pawn blunders the H pun
moving the King to h6 would allow King
at five so we're just going move by move
here to make sure we've established that
every move played was forced by Comodo
Bishop c8 now bishop of three the bishop
comes to f5 because coming to a new
diagonal to defend does make a lot of
sense and so black is not going to get
to that diagonal says white King III
Bishop to c8 and now came to Defour and
here we get the move Bishop to g4 we're
gonna circle back to this one along with
the line that I think does Komodos the
best drawing chances here in a minute
because I did spend a lot of time trying
to prove that black could not just sit
tight this is a key idea because it does
say that you can't go to d5 right away
you would actually lose your bishop so
white does have to come up with what I
kind of figured out as well maybe the
only move that wins here or at least the
only move that has a winning plan other
moves just rinse and repeat the same
position so we'll come back to King h6
but Bishop g4 was played and after the
move Bishop e4 check the King moves we
see that the reason black played King g6
and Bishop g4 is because it doesn't want
to sit with the King on h6 it now has
officially agreed I need to run in
abandon ship and get to the Queen side
as fast as possible
why because here's what happens in the
game
III came to see eight if the bishop had
gone to see eight now black can-can has
no has no skewer on Bishop e7 there's no
skewer to win the bishop King to e7 is
met by King to see six and after the
move d5 you have the amazing move King
to see seven this is the only move that
wins you don't take the pawn and allow
the black King to get closer instead you
play King to c7 and force the bishop out
of its favorite square after which you
can take a six and the a pawn along with
the fact that the King is shielding the
King from the Queen side is much faster
than anything black has these are the
type of lines that I think best
illustrate kind of the brilliance of the
sacrifice right it's not just that it
started with this move Bishop f3 to take
the diagonal of the bishop but the fact
that the d5 square becomes an entry
point for the King to walk in if black
tries his best to hold on to the pawn we
don't even need to try to win our pawn
back it's all about the right King
position and making sure that that
weakness I couldn't get up before is
finally falling so this is a line that
really shows that idea instead in the
game after Bishop b3 black played King's
ei and after Bishop takes a6 King to d8
we see King e for King c7 Bishop b5 and
we immediately start to realize just how
lost black is dual threats here not just
of advancing the a pawn but also king of
four King g5 and Bishop de 8 are enough
to make black panic after King to b8
king of four black does indeed do so he
plays not yet he plays king c7 but after
Bishop e8 he realizes he can't just sit
around anymore and shuffle the King and
he finally plays d5 allowing stockfish
to come back into the center King e5
Bishop f3 the bishop goes back to b5 and
the point is that the White King is
improving itself enough to come and make
sure the a pawn will finish the job
again this whole line which is what
happened in the game just shows you it's
the it's the power of the pawn not who
had the pass pawn first I guess and the
fact that there's a check here just to
show you the line doesn't do anything
the King can come right back and take
and you think you've achieved opposition
and now what do you got to do you got to
go right back to guard it and why she
was gonna come right back just like in
the game so d4 wouldn't have done
anything king a7 was played bishop
free king to be six and ultimately we
get a position where the dual threats of
a seven combined with the fact that you
still have not taken care of that second
weakness we talked about long ago makes
the endgame impossible to hold Bishop a
six and black isn't fools looks wrong
the bishop cannot stay gardening the
checkmate on b7 and guard the d3 pawn so
he plays d2 but now on Bishop e2 we see
the same thing the bishop has no ability
to both guard the h5 pawn and guard the
threat of Bishop f3 checkmate at the
same time so classic Komodo fashion gets
a knight again but just to show it
doesn't matter you move anywhere else
Bishop f3 is checkmate in two if you
move the bishop on this diagonal I keep
an eye on the D 1 square pick up that
pollen and then start to march Harry up
the board so there was no choice but to
do what was done and this is really I'm
only showing you the end of this game
because apparently we've learned that a
lot of people like seeing checkmate on
the board so might as well make that
happen right let's show the checkmate
all the way out but this particular
position does show the threat I guess
and it's going to help us as we back up
and go into what were the other options
Komodo had we now understand that
winning the a pawn even if it's a 2
versus 2 battle a and H versus D and H
is enough for white to win so if giving
up the a pawn was not the best idea for
black what if instead of this King rush
over we already saw that trying to guard
the pawn here was not good enough right
the King could enter what if instead of
rushing the King over in the beginning
black decided to keep his King on this
side of the board all the way back to
the line I analyzed instead of Bishop g4
which allowed the line we saw with check
and Bishop d3 right watch all hamlet of
the pawn black just sits tight and plays
King aged six I think this is actually
some of the most instructive stuff to
show why the endgame is winning king b5
does not work it's as fewer moving the
bishop
let's see lines I've analyzed like
Bishop e2 allowed Bishop e7 now the
bishop guards both the pawn and the King
entry if you move the bishop somewhere
else at this point the King might even
consider is getting active so sitting
tight but leaving this diagonal is not
ideal you can
enter here right away and you also want
to keep an eye on the pond so the only
way to do that is the move Bishop to c6
this move stops the threat of a skewer
prepares can be 5 and does keep an eye
on the H pawn via a new diagonal of EA
so you basically solved the problem you
couldn't advance as long as there was a
threat of a skewer right but you can
advance with the bishop still keeping
the King trapped and now no longer a
threat of the skewer time for black to
panic there's a lot of moves here and
again I encourage you to check out all
of them over at the blog to see why it's
winning by force but I'm gonna go with
the ones that that feel the most
important and instructed to prove
White's winning King coming back to g6
makes a lot of sense again here note
that Bishop e6 the stop King d5 would
just allow Bishop e7 and the pawn does
fall because Bishop c4 is not a
possibility we've already established
losing the a pawn is the fastest pawn on
the board that's why we kind of
Tarantino this and showed you the ending
so we shouldn't have to look at lines
where white just wins the a6 pawn
anymore it's too fast so instead we see
king g6 Bishop E a check forcing the
King back and now the King comes in now
even in this line where it looks clear
doomsday d6 is gonna fall and we're
gonna come over only the right plan for
white is going to win and I'm gonna let
you pause the video here to see if you
want to try to come up with it not much
time because we're already kind of
hitting that 20 minute mark of a very
very long lesson and lecture that
hopefully you're enjoying the only way
to have a very forceful win here for
white is the move King to e5 now let me
show you what happens in variations
where you just run the King over seems
like this should be an easy win right
we're way too fast
we're gonna bring the bishop and win the
a6 pawn what could black do make sure
you know your king upon endings kids
King to d5 is a draw the whole point is
that Bishop takes a6 allows Bishop takes
and King to c6 and we have the King
trapped on the edge of the board at this
point even giving a check would not
matter the King goes to d6 any trade
always allows the trap if you go back I
go back if you move the King I come in
so suddenly we see a line that is crazy
as it looks black has actually corner to
corner fast enough to have a theoretical
draw because what we know about corner
pawns King to e5 on the other hand says
that I'm gonna make sure I pry
tries the right thing which is keeping
your king in prison while I improve this
bishop and only once my bishop is in the
ideal spot will I then abandon and run
to get the pawn that line is shown in a
variation like this
Bishop to b7 King did you now that we've
improved it the bishop is two Tempe
ahead the King okay actually King if the
King ever comes back that's the other
reason King me five is good if the King
ever comes back you now bring the King
over and win the H pawn positions like
this are just a matter of time the
bishop will come over and win h5 you
have no counter play at all and the hpm
will be way too fast for anything on
this side of the board not to mention
the fact that the pawn is still an ally
score means maybe white actually is
better chance to win it than black so
one of the other key points of King me
five is it not just prepares to shoulder
the king which is one of those awesome
geometry lessons where we don't just run
for a pawn and let the King out right
but it also says if you do try to run
your King out prematurely this is the
key that I will switch pawns and forget
a6 and go for h5 with my King on g5 you
guys can tell excited I'm freaking
getting about this endgame because it's
amazing I mean honestly this is this
part of it I spent so much time
analyzing this because I just couldn't
get my head around why this was a forced
win but again with the right technique
you've emphasized and prioritizes the
right things if the King leaves his
blockade too early I'll win the easier
pawn if he stays tight and the bishop
keeps moving I will only then improve my
bishop enough that if the bishop
continues to move like this only now
I've gained essentially three moves do I
abandon this side of the board run to
the b-pawn and I'm Way ahead of the
Tempe now obviously here the variation I
gave us King g4 because I mean if you've
been this way you're actually you're
actually just way behind right you're
not in a position the King needs to jump
from a 5 to c6 but Kings don't move like
ponies so without the ability to get to
c6 you're just you're just dead in the
water
so in this line I just show so at that
point you might as well try to run to
this side of the board
but again way too slow the pawn advances
Bishop e7 a7 a8 Queen Bob's your uncle
for those that are really into play like
Karpov technique I'm pretty sure I also
analyze bishop of three instead of king
b6 here is also winning if you just want
to say like you know
I'm not even gonna let you have the
satisfaction of winning the pawn for
free I'll get it and then go all the way
back to de pawn but the main variation I
gave and as far as the critical reason
why King II five wins and why this idea
of prioritizing both weaknesses is why
this hanging is winning is why the move
King aged six back here instead of what
was played in the game by Comodo Bishop
g4 also would have lost the game so as
long as stockfish didn't fall for this
fewer he would have lost I could keep
going on about this and the analysis is
super complicated right here doing my
best to make sure I highlight all the
variations that I I promised myself I
would and on that note I want to go back
to the foreshadowing of the beginning of
the video and scrolling up we're gonna
go back to this position where instead
of the move that was played it's
possible that the one drawing chance I'm
gonna find the move number right now
apologies for that the one drawing
chance might have been right here so to
refresh your memory what did we see we
saw a deadlock in terms of the blockade
why couldn't break through until this b4
idea one other point I want to show
actually is why didn't the d5 pawn sack
work in this position okay why doesn't
the d5 pawn sack work before you've
traded the B pause I'll show that good
question the main point is that if you
try four instead of sitting tight
keeping your eye on the a6 pawn right
which was the main reason d5 couldn't be
taken if you go for stock fishes Bishop
a5 idea before the b-pawn has been
traded for the C pawn the main problem
is that now on takes and you try to come
back black has C for stopping the bishop
from hitting a6 and after the bishop
moves and the D pawn gets rolling I'm
not even sure who's better in a position
like Bishop Bishop e2 Bishop f7 probably
white is maybe not losing but I actually
don't know so just to answer the
question that may or may not have been
asked in your head is why was it
necessary to start this whole plan of
bringing the King back and over to the
Queen side before you sacrifice the D
pawn that's why because if you gave up
the pawn and allowed that bishop to
block the diagonal white would never
have the chance to do what it did in the
game
ultimately we came back to this Bishop
f5 position if you remember and again we
gave up the D pawn and force the Bishop
back instead of a pawn coming to c4 so
that answers that question
the last question I posed at the
beginning of the video is really a key
point to try to understand this engine
in this position right here right now
was there an opportunity for black to
find out or realize to himself an anti
counterintuitive computer style that he
needs to give up material to try to hold
when you don't see a winning path for
your opponent I wouldn't recommend this
for human or computer right it's very
difficult to change gears of just
sitting tight when you're like what's
the point of beat what are you doing
right but in hindsight this position
offers one very instructive drawing idea
I wanted to show if you play King of
five and white takes and then you play
King II five one of the key ideas is
that after the move for example Bishop
f3 to go to guard the pawn black can
play king of for Bishop moves and came
back to e5 and the main idea is that if
white tries to advance the H pawn black
doesn't take d5 but goes back to the
dark squares and suddenly we see the
same blockade that had been held here
for the last several moves on the board
the pawn guards e5 the bishop guards f5
and the king guards g5 King to g5
threatens Bishop f5 check not allowing
King f4 and after the bishop moves we
check the King back and you can rinse
and repeat any time the King is not
threatening to come to f4 the King can
go back any time the bishop is gonna
attacking the pawn the bishop can go
back as soon as you come up to g5 you're
threatening Bishop f5 check King backs
up here you can even go to f5 because if
h6 you gathered the pawn and as I showed
in lines like this I actually could not
find a clear way in for white the pawns
guard key entry points and the King and
Bishop do the same job they've been
doing since before the D pawn was
sacrificed so I spent a lot of time
analyzing this and I couldn't find a way
that white creates a zoogs Wang which
would need to be
this position with black to move but the
problem is even that doesn't work it's
just like before we're not just it's not
that the bishop even has b7 the bishop
has f5 check and you can force the key
even if it was black to move you can
check force the King back and then go
right back so this particular blockading
setup of giving up the H pawn I think
might have been Komodos last chance to
draw very difficult to see though it is
instructive to kind of think about the
blockade you have and don't give up on
it so early however I came up after
analyzing that I came up with the idea
that white has and of course it was
obvious in hindsight I don't need the D
pawn I've already won the H pawn just
like the idea that stockfish came up
with you just give up the pawn with King
to C 3 and after takes you played bishop
g6 and only then rush the H pawn as now
for example in variations like this you
might blockade my pawn but you haven't
stopped my winning plan that I used in
the game of entering on the D file so
instead I analyze d5 as a natural way to
try to stop that but now we can force
the King back
h7 was also winning but once the King
has left we get to go right back to the
same plan Whitehead all along which is
to ultimately win the a6 pawn I'll just
show it just for kicks and giggles just
to remind everybody I don't even want
the D pawn the whole point is you're
getting this bishop away and only then
taking and ultimately winning cuz of the
a pawn so I teased you at the beginning
of the video was King of five the only
chance comodo had to draw the answers
now the engine was winning the entire
time especially once this b4 idea was
shown but I do think that last little
instructor blockade that black has might
be something that's worth noting
especially when we consider in hindsight
that there really was no way to deal
with this super brilliant sacrifice of
the D pawn once black did allow white to
come all the way back over here to the
King side so I've never spent more time
analyzing an endgame by myself me myself
and some chess engines on my chest based
let alone trying to really understand an
endgame that I did here one the one
endgame that from start to finish did
not optically look winning but in the
end we learned something about two
weaknesses being more important than one
even to the point where you can lose
your weakness not as a trade for one but
straight up
if it means that those two weaknesses
don't go anywhere and you're given new
avenues to put your opponent under
pressure that's that's really what what
we could summarize on a high level of
what stockfish did it is it is zoogs
Wong at its finest
but but not in the not in the obvious
senses we normally think of it creating
new avenues for both the king and the
bishop by sacrificing that D pawn were
what that move 99 Bishop of five the
move 99 Bishop of five double exclaimed
that will be remembered forever I guess
really was all about just backing up to
show it one last time on the board
something that will will forever be
remembered so hope you enjoyed it if you
did and click on one of these other
videos here from our Channel and keep
keep watching chess content apologize
for the slightly longer election than
normal but as a chess fan I felt that I
had to do this game justice and really
try to understand it
I even bounced around some as you could
see making sure that as I remembered a
key idea I took the time to go over it
so maybe now you take a look at this and
you click that blog below come on click
on my blog and go check it out
if you want to understand even more
about it I think we can all become
better chess players when we see
masterpieces like this one so thank you
so much and I will see you around on
chess calm